[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you know I tell you to sit down because
otherwise
[Laughter]
crowd didn't like this before me to get
here no and they just would sit down
somebody said one of his better speeches
you've got dosed and any patients
because they never sat down it was one
but we love you people and I know
they're just tell me John that is a
record to have people here that people
in all the ballrooms all over this
beautiful hotel and that people outside
closed-circuit somehow you people know
relocation but I'm honored to be here
with the hard-working men and women who
helped millions of families live the
American dream and that's so true the
incredible members of the National
Association of Realtors and they might
know very well I want to thank my friend
he is my friend my competitor for a
while but he was still my friend
secretary ben Carson
to break that put him in charge of HUD
firstly is a very smart guy adaptable I
said baby what do you know about growing
to say how much I would like the hip
hook and you know what didn't take you
long bit of bed and he got some of the
smartest people I also want to thank the
president of the National Association of
Realtors John Smith
we're CEO Bob Goldberg respected guys
vice-president Tracy Casper
a friend and thank you much and your
entire team for everything that you do
to support me I took a little sabbatical
for eight years you know
[Applause]
the regulation got many more importance
we did regulation cutting where you
couldn't build jobs you couldn't build
anything you'd have a puddle on your
hand and they considered it to be one of
the great lakes of the world so you have
a puddle and it informed more than twice
a year
we used to go in a puddle they called it
a lake became lake constriction actually
in Bedford New York I was building that
development there's going to go some
really luxury beautiful houses
the taxes are going I they're doing a
mansion tax now you know what that is
right they want to be your partner
that's not good at the mansion tax I
just heard about that one but you know
the environmental stuff was very tough
it was getting worse divorce Sophie and
I actually had this beautiful piece of
land two hundred sixteen acres then I
was going to do something with it and
then I decided to because they can help
more people but Tracy they had a little
area where water would sort of form
water rain and all of a sudden they
found out that you build a Molina does
that make sense I can't build on the
land because it was considered for all
intents and purposes a lake and how did
people find out about the lake my
consultant told them because this way
you have to use your environmental
consultant longer pay more money to get
you out of the jam
and see them up in Albany what are you
doing here and they wouldn't make it it
bored or difficult she had a higher a
lot of people but that's what we getting
rid of we're getting rid a lot of the
regulations and frankly I've had some
great business leaders talking to me and
if they had their choice between we have
the biggest tax cut bill in the history
of our country and we also in that bill
that included Anwar one of the great oil
sights in all of the world in Alaska and
we got rid of the individual mandate
which is by far the biggest problem with
Obamacare when you paid a lot of money
for the privilege not to pay a lot of
money for health care how about that one
who's the only thing you paid not to
have it you paid a fortune not to have
it and we got rid of it so but we are
doing regulations and I think
regulations frankly maybe are a bigger
reason for our tremendous success as a
country over the last two and a half
years maybe even bigger than the tax
cuts I mean it's incredible what's
happening
I just left Louisiana building a
tremendous LNG terminal LNG we find it's
ten billion dollars one of the biggest
in the world it must be a mile long I've
never say anything like this it's a
building but it's all pipes is all pipes
there's no spaces or pipes they didn't
use any space bed and I've never seen
it's incredible ten billion dollars ten
thousand jobs Louisiana now they're
going to do more of them and if you look
over the last 40 years I don't think we
built a refinery or certainly we built
very few of them and now we have a lot
of refineries going up in great
locations and it's really it's really
incredible
he thought that ever see a refinery
built but we worked with the EPA and we
worked with people that were really
stuffing then these people were in they
were in the process of getting permits
for many many years and we helped them
where we got em very very quickly and
they've invested tremendous amounts of
money that's sold out so now for the 20
years it's all sold out see that's so
different than an office building you
sign a lease and you get your financing
right
these people they sign with countries
and they get their financing but I think
it's bigger and probably even better if
you won another tooth and a happy and
it's a lot of people that are working
and we did we did that but we did many
of them we did the pipeline as you know
the big pipelines the Keystone XL
pipeline 48,000 jobs and the Dakota
access pipeline and these are tremendous
things and frankly environmentally great
better than tracking it down better than
putting into drains better than doing
any other way and it goes to the various
parts of the country that Dida fantastic
and these are things that would never
have happened if other people got into
office I could Omer say if almost
anybody else in the world got into
office but before I begin
that we've just reached an agreement
with Canada and Mexico and we'll be
selling our product into those countries
without the imposition of tariffs well
major tariffs as you know Canada's been
for years and rivertrek relationship
with Canada the Prime Minister we have a
great relationship but they've been
charging us extremely high tariffs as
much as two hundred and eighty five
percent or more for our agricultural
products which is an absolute barrier
it's essentially a barrier in other
words when you pay twenty two hundred
eighty five guess what you know what
they're saying we don't want your
business so it was a barrier to our
farmers they have to do business with
them to our farmers being able to sell
product in there so that deal is going
to be a fantastic deal for our country
and hopefully Congress will approve the
u.s. MCA quickly and then the great
farmers and manufacturers and steel
plants will make our economy even more
successful than it already is if that's
possible which it is possible
we could have the greatest economy in
the history of our country we could have
you look at the unemployment numbers the
best since 1969 and in a very short
period it would be somebody would just
go a little bit further it'll be the
best in history the unemployment numbers
are great but the employment numbers are
even better we have the most people
working today than at any time in the
history of our country people are going
to go out and buy a house hello
everybody and I will pay you six
percentage
I'll pay you one percent I was famished
[Applause]
don't worry nobody accepted it don't
fear what I Drive like that now but I
get it down to four or five minutes
that's okay
I had one occasion to Palm Beach believe
it a hundred million dollar house can
you relate it and the broker did a
fantastic job and I taught the broker
I'm paying you more than you supposed to
he got a bid is sold the house for one
hundred million dollars he believed
voted for thirty nine that are so good
for hundred wasn't immediate a couple
years that's okay I have painted inside
a little bit of the paint I call it a
turnaround
this is when the k-12 the market through
a really attraction to produce a
situation with the the owner and
tremendous two good brokers actually but
I paid a more money than they actually
asked for I made it deal with them and I
paid a more and I've done that a lot
I've also done
but really there's nothing like a good
broker I mean you no different than a
great search
[Applause]
[Music]
renting the leeks and cook yourself and
honestly I've seen I've seen cases when
you give it to the wrong person
and you just sit and you just die with
it and then the right person comes along
and it's like genius it's like genius
[Applause]
you know who I am and you know they are
but you have some tremendously talented
people in this room I know this business
so well I love this business and you
have people that can really good job
that very few people can do and frankly
if you wouldn't do another business you
do great with that too but there's
something about the real estate world
president I write down those streets
initiative Wow is that place nice what
could you do with that look at that site
in the nation wait a minute I have to do
[Applause]
I love your business and we're here
today because Realtors play a special
role in the American economy and that's
true I would think it's the largest
business in this country when you add
you add up all the family firms and the
big real estate firms and the single
family all donors the ones in to allow
homes thousands and thousands
it's bigger than oil and gas which is
big it's bigger than car speaking than
anything group as a group you're a
tremendously big business and a very
powerful business politically when a
young family eats room to grow when a
new job sparks a new adventure
a brand new beautiful city when parents
want to find the right neighborhood
schools for their children Americans put
our trust in you
I'm going good in what business you have
where your home your homes
[Music]
you have a speech and
so so far this is Olaf but they don't
know what I know and they don't know
what you know to say my speeches and our
economy's great but they don't know
these kinds of little things little
things that make you great home is where
our hearts are and all of you as
Americans you find a home for the ones
that you love the most
so today I want to thank all of you this
is a time of opportunity never been a
better time in my opinion to the build
and break ground in America people are
making a lot of money and they're doing
well and jobs are so good so many
positive things are happening we made it
a nearly six billion jobs since my
election including more than 120,000
real estate
[Music]
[Applause]
20,000 more people that we have to
compete with that
we've also and we're getting off welfare
we think about five million people off
of food stamps you know what that costs
first what strategy but you know what
that cost so they're often out there
working so they're actually paying taxes
instead of really expressing a lot of
money very expensive and very important
women to more than 60%
[Music]
so I think the man should sue the women
for discrimination
[Applause]
and after years of stagnation wages are
rising fast with the quickest growth for
blue-collar workers the best suggesting
to halt and people don't know how
everyone's doing great the rich doing
great did not so rich is doing great the
middle-income is doing the best but the
best of all the blue-collar worker has
the biggest percentage we are taking out
this power out of Washington these bad
people and returning it to the American
people where it belongs
just think about Comey
grazie swap swap tell me
Brennan flapper with drain the swamp
[Applause]
at the heart of America's revival under
the massive tax cuts that are signed
into law a year ago and they are like
rocket fuel for America's economy the
typical family of four earning $75,000
is now saving more than $2,000 for their
income taxes money they didn't put for
anything they were including saving many
small business owners are here today and
you cannot deduct up to 20% of their
business income
[Applause]
[Music]
but it is pretty amazing yeah the other
thing is expensive and we've also done
something that in this room for farmers
and ranchers for you know small
businesses fairly big businesses
actually we've virtually eliminated
leave your real estate company to your
child or your children they like real
estate had an aptitude and you love them
and they love you other people I've seen
parents that are so badly treated by
their kids and who does not love your
child but what we have now is because a
lot of times it happened with the
farmers were some cases they'll enrich
but not but the farms and the diet would
be taxed from the value of the land
losing the business you have no tax to
pay anymore and nobody talks about to me
that's a big thing
and thanks to the opportunity zones
forbid Martians to work
made possible by tax reform we're making
enormous investments in distressed
communities tremendously I will tell you
this and then I think you can agree with
me to agree by the way he doesn't he
will tell me that it's amazing the way
that I had no idea
Kim Scott was very much involved that we
did it and you know I've been hearing
about these things for 40 years these
things have become tremendously
tremendously successful in areas where
money was never invested very very big
powerful which people are spending
tremendous amounts of money they have
but we got them to open their wallets
and the jobs that are being created in
neighborhoods where people wouldn't go
before the opportunity zones and it's
starting to be seen and it started about
it's a great achievement for Kim Scott
it's a great achievement for Ben Carson
it's really some of the people in those
birds that hurt people then that work to
us would you say that four or five
people that really were in the front the
forefront but you - I say
in particular I'm gonna get myself in
trouble
but they know they did a good job right
there
so we're off to be joined today by one
of the pages leading the charge or
opportunities own development a
fantastic man a fantastic football
player by the way for those of you that
remember he's still young a longtime
member of the Association Bob Turner
[Applause]
Thank You mr. editor what about me
thank you so much for this great economy
[Applause]
it really did the opportunity zones of
creating so many opportunities for
everybody across this country and you
came to Millington Tennessee about a
mile from where you landed we own 47
acres that are an opportunity so we're
developing 247 units of apartments that
we're building 71 single-family home
locks on this 47 acres we will create
about 40 million dollars of economic
development
Billington has not seen any new
developments for over 10 years only
apartments very few houses in it's home
of the Naval Air Station
they don't base with your fine pages and
it's it's going to make a change in that
time we're also developing a large
development in Memphis it's 1,500
apartments a hotel and about 35,000
square-foot a retail space that will
create about 400 million you can only
develop it's not an opportunity zone but
it's creating a tremendous amount of
jobs
so it's Realtors across this country
we've been talking about this all this
week and I've told them they are the
catalyst for this opportunity zone with
mr. Carson and press the trunk and
without it we would not be able to
revitalize these communities that need
help I had the opportunity to come to
the White House and represent our
realtors in your economic summit for the
opportunity zone and I thought it was
all about real estate just about
workforce
it's about housing it's about every kind
of had economic development you can do
in these zones and it's really gonna
make a difference as you said the
money's flowing the day that you are
released those rich rules the faucet
turned on there is hundreds of millions
of dollars looking for a place to invest
in your communities and this group here
mr. president is in the center
our religions are going to create this
situation in every city in town across
the country and be the catalyst for
building these opportunities owns how to
put people to work
[Music]
[Applause]
no notes no nothing that's from the
heart and I have to tell you a manner
just why I introduced them but I'm gonna
ask them to take a little bit of a state
of your president because Jonas maybe
you really wanted trauma
[Applause]
so as our economy booms like never
before we're lifting millions of our
citizens from welfare to work dependence
to independence and poverty to
prosperity but as everyone in this
business does nothing kills economic
growth faster than government
bureaucrats regulation with all that
power and not enough common sense lots
of bad things can happen quickly and
that's why we're waging a historic
deregulation campaign that especially
affects the real estate business and
that's liberating our citizens from
bureaucracy and freeing our economy to
soar higher than ever and it can
continue to go up to see the disastrous
results of over-regulation you take a
look at what's going on in California
housing costs are among the highest in
the country development restrictions
make it sometimes impossible to build
what they do I mean years and years of
turmoil I have one school the Coastal
Commission oh they're fun to deal with
if you're really good you'll have your
permits within 20 years or not happen
within 20 years we vote no wait a minute
we've been looking at these things for
20 years we vote no how about that how
about what you're looking at a permit
you've devoted millions and millions of
dollars and you go into that hearing
after years and you have no idea if they
get a vote yes or no and oftentimes
they're going to now so we're trying to
end that stated local regulations can
easily add 200 thousand dollars to the
price of a single home and it is no
surprise that in California and I don't
want to single them out but they have a
train going up now you know this fast
train you heard about this
I mean you people know how to build on
time on budget preferably ahead of time
and under budget right this is a trade
that's not working out so well it's a
fast train without a bullet train so
it's not that fast
and who's gonna go from San Francisco to
Los Angeles and then the thing called
cost overruns happened and many of you
know but it's well it's in the thing
connections I said we're not paying any
more money for it California's lost
control and it's an incredible thing
gotta be a straight run and they build a
section and then they build another
section way way and then another section
and then they want to hook it up it
doesn't work
you
to set you down with sod all over again
this is like a confession like hundreds
of millions over budget totally out of
control so think of this think of this
it was going from San Francisco to Los
Angeles now the price have to be very
very high much more expensive than
Southwest Airlines which goes in one
fifth of time so say what are they doing
you got an airline the ghost from San
Francisco to Los Angeles much faster and
it's less funny
so does this walk and again it's not
that
meaning it's slow meaning meaning it's
obsolete right you know it's obsolete
before if you gonna do it you do the
bullet train
[Music]
[Applause]
you won't have cars and I've got built
it's called forest management because I
was after an initiated when I saw was so
horrific with some of the fires so many
people killed
the fire was you talk about bullets the
fire was like a bullet so on the train
they had a solution the solution was
we'll make it shorter so instead of
going from San Francisco to Los Angeles
and now you go from this town to another
for billions of tops and they think they
can do it for just billions of dollars
more than the original projection these
people increase so I told the great
Elaine Chao Secretary of Transportation
I said Elaine it's over for them it has
been going on for many years long before
I got there I would have told them I
would have said listen if of airplanes
much faster what are we doing what are
we doing and I also would have done the
super modern thing and we would have had
time
[Applause]
three people order today so we're
reversing years of calamitous trade
policies that gutted the American middle
class nearly two decades ago politicians
in Washington place China into the WTO
of the World Trade Organization one of
the great catastrophes in history of our
country as far as fair distance between
that and NAFTA get to real beauties
allowing it to largely do whatever they
want to do to the American marketplace
during that time we lost nearly
one-in-four manufacturing jobs and
racked up trillions and trillions of
dollars in trade deficits but the lumps
you know
[Laughter]
but they took out a lot of the things in
ago she ate can't do that can't do that
you've been doing that too long tour
what precedents that have no clue what
was happening and you can't do that so
we're putting in tariffs you have 25
percent tariffs on two hundred and fifty
billion dollars and so many people say
our people pay a little bit but it's
worth it China subsidizes these big
plans so it's not really coming and they
keep the prices saying they're
subsidized and also you take a look at
what's happening if we built here there
are no tariffs you know people don't
know sir if we build here you know right
now we're you become dependent on buying
things or something if we put a little
factory or whatever to make whatever
product they buy a lot of people now
looking at it and the other alternative
to buy from another country with a
non-tariff where they're treating us
more fairly and everything so it's
hundreds of billions of dollars and out
of that we're going to give a portion of
it to our farmers because these are
great Patriots these are people that
don't want anything they just want a
fair playing surface and our farmers are
doing
[Applause]
very happy very but you're talking about
maybe 15 billion dollars to our farmers
out of one hundred and twenty five
billion dollars and they're really you
have to understand they've taken the
brunt because China to negotiate with us
said well we're not gonna buy any of
your products so I called sonny Perdue
our great Secretary of Agriculture at
seven I said Sonny what what's the
biggest amount they ever spent in this
country said about fifteen million
people would say eighteen nineteen but
basically 15 million I said so let's
take fifteen billion and what we'll do
is the farmers will sell at a lower
price because of competition and what we
do is we'll make up the difference we
have a little bit of a difference we
make up the difference so they agree we
do incredibly great but you have to
understand they use the farmer because
the farmers were off the truck and the
farms what people don't realize you go
back 18 years the farms are gonna go in
like this not just you know I'm here two
and a half years could you can go back
18 years and you see once that hasn't
worked at NAFTA is pretty bad for the
farmers a lot of people don't realize it
they get stuck on it out of habit
but we're taking care of our farmers and
everybody
you can play literally but these are
pictures I watched some people on
television today because some of them
don't even know what I just told you
they said you know we're hurting but I
know that China is doing terrible things
to us for many many years and we want
our president to fix it and this is the
only president has had the courage of
the guts to fix it
I don't know they may even be better
than the rippers
[Applause]
I'll take a quick survey farmer so I had
recently I had about 22 of them in my
office in the White House in the Oval
Office the room right next to a
political conference room and we're
sitting there then practically not doing
the business with Canada actually
because immediately you know in order to
negotiate this step by from the phone
erector set puts a political pressure
you know they think it's very unique
exactly to get it all but I said we
don't want that I said you gotta be
kidding you're the only group that's
ever seen that country's come in they
won't help everybody wants help they
weren't free what do you mean by that we
don't want that we want to produce
I've been on this land with my family
for 150 years he said my family's been
here four hundred fifty-two years or
something
he said we just want a fair it's not
fair what they've done to us with Canada
Georgie is two hundred and eighty five
percent tax we took care of that with
all of the things that happens and then
China every time they want to negotiate
with the United States they stopped
buying farm product and China's massive
you know they can buy a lot of stuff
online and they use the farmers to
negotiate and especially with me because
they know I love the farmers and they
know the farmers you look in the middle
of this country that
Oh countries want military protection
you want wealthy countries
it's almost as bad as trade we get it
all sick stuff after years of building
up other countries
we're finally building our and I've
directed federal aid
you know I tell people about Nate I'm an
aspiring but I got them to spend a
hundred billion dollars while we were
paying essentially for the most of the
data believe it or not that's not here
you know it's big stuff but the European
Union treats us I would say worse than
China they're just smaller can you
believe it they have trade barriers they
don't want to farm products that want a
car so they said Mercedes Benzes in here
like their cookies they said BMWs here
we hardly tax them at all job we only
tax them at all yet you want to send our
cars over there forget it you want to
send our agricultural products over the
oh I'm sorry we don't we have our own
farmers it's a very unfair situation
medical equipments a big business
believe it or not you know all the big
equipment medical stuff they we make the
best of the world well they change the
standard so that we power equipment it
doesn't qualify they made it not a
higher standard just a different
standard so that our equipment now
doesn't qualify without these companies
going and spending a fortune to make
equipment that's not as good so it's a
very unfair thing so we protect that we
spend hundreds of billions of dollars
protecting them and then they take
advantage of us so trade it's not it's
not fair we lost one hundred and eighty
billion dollars with the European Union
but we all love unit we love Europe I
think they got to be careful with Europe
frankly but we all love Europe but it's
not fair the way they treat her so I
just tell you that I'm directing federal
agencies
addressing the accelerate the approval
process for new roads and bridges
highways and we're taking 21 years to
get an approval there's a highway in the
state none so far away took 20 years to
get it approved and then an opening
fairly recently not a big road but by
the time it ended up it was 20 years
late they spent ten to the million
dollars on environmental impact
statements the road was a dead straight
road the first Road dead astray so that
you had a rough night you can go
straight now it's a road that goes this
way because of nesting different things
nest
so the road ends up being twice as long
and curving my calendar let's go
hundred-percent shot you're in a deep
trouble we've got these barriers right
without the barriers Wow Wow so my
father and I want to build that thing
for nothing
but nothing and it costs every hundreds
of millions of dollars and just years
and you look at the environmental
impacts Avis I actually brought one to
one speech at Brookline and it was
literally it was this high and there
were like three other sections it was
just nonsense so we're stopping that
we're trying to get it down it takes 17
18 years to get a highway
we're trying to get it down to 1 we have
it down to two I'm getting rid of the
quadruples you know you have many
quadruples yep so will you need 10
agencies to approve the exact same thing
so let's say you're doing really well
you get Carson to approve it you get all
these different people to approve and
then you have one agency you can get
that's the end of that project so we're
simplifying it and we've done I think
been a great job on that and we have it
down to a much lower number properly two
years would like to get it down to one
and it may get rejected you know it's
not environmentally good if it's not
good we're gonna get will reject it very
quickly but at least you know so we have
we've done a good job with that very
good job I think again a lot of jobs
we've read local lenders from the heavy
crunchy community banks and threatening
the housing market Pocahontas had an
agency
I mean she's a disaster she was she
enjoyed destroying these local Enders I
mean I think she got pleasure out of
destroying beautiful local lenders who
have been lending to your clients and
probably yourselves for years and they
were going out of business and they were
they were living in fear oh god if
that's another
she's doing really well so far her beer
commercial
[Laughter]
how about the kid did you see the way
she got the kick did anybody see she
wanted a job
pent-up anger she's an angry person but
you don't want making it very tough one
people that you know you know exactly
what I'm talking about and now we have
that running beautifully and Alana in
there they're nice people by some
estimates under the previous
administration CFPB regulations cost
threated years he's stunning
six billion dollars well that's what
we're talking about that was her baby
and she had the man who was in charge of
that running in the great state of Ohio
but it might did a good job and I did a
good job we fought and your current
governor came from behind and he was
down by six or seven points with a
couple of days left we went out we made
a rally like you wouldn't believe in the
great state of Ohio and he ended up
winning about six or seven points last
year we roll back the dodd-frank
regulations
I didn't know this is a banking
convention I don't
you know you know is happening to Magnus
right John I mean you know I was
happening to bankers bankers have being
crushed and they're being threatened and
these are people who are destroyed
[Music]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
there's my people I'm worse than they
are the worst it's probably a good thing
because this same man I don't know where
these people are coming from but they
put out false you know they say
confidential sources HIPPA donors they
never write the names of people
[Applause]
[Applause]
my ready man are still many and ready
still dominate the market with no real
competition from the private sector and
the taxpayers are still in the it not a
crisis should happen and this is a
pretty urgent problem we're doing well
with it now it's well managed great
people but it's a pretty big problem and
it's really a problem that other of the
government should be doing so we're
looking at different alternatives we
have many geniuses looking ahead and
we'll figure something out but
and that's why I recently directed the
Department of Treasury and HUD then to
develop the framework for a modern
housing finance system
I want to get people to do this and one
that welcomes the private-sector
competition to pass these critical
reforms to modernize our housing
programs and to achieve our more
affordable housing to get rid of
ridiculous regulations so you can build
and build quickly and beautifully
actually you're putting more money into
the house because of the sin of spending
of a ridiculous paperwork you'll be able
to buy better lumber and better floor
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
their chief executive
[Music]
[Applause]
Nevada we have statewide Association
health plans offered with four members
from Nevada and Las Vegas we cover
currently over a thousand lives in just
the last couple of months we've had this
over 27% of those people were currently
were uninsured before our plant
completely uninsured for those that were
insured they are saving an average of
150 to 300 dollars a month
saving an estimated two million dollars
in Nevada this year and that money goes
right back into their businesses and
right back into those communities
I have one member who could not afford
to insure his family he let stealth
lapse needing urgent hip and back
surgery when he was able to finally get
this affordable full coverage care in
Nevada under the Association health plan
he was able to in his words get back on
track
beat the bread winner for his family
again and make himself great
another really critical part of
Association health plans is what it's
done for our rural communities and
before our Association health plans our
rural communities have one choice want a
product one plan through hometown health
we have they have offered multiple
insurance products to the rural areas
that gives our rural Realtors a choice
now of their health plans a choice of
the products that they use to insure
themselves and their families we
recently went a couple of colleagues and
I went and met at the White House with
the Department of Labor because
Association health plans are under
attack and we're working with the
Department of Labor to ensure that this
critical need for our Realtors is
allowed to continue it's critically
important to our realtors to have
choices to fully affordable and full
coverage health plans
the great state and it is under attack
you know these health plans are because
they want to keep the public deal going
and it's a shame and their fighting is
so hard but we are saving a tremendous
amount of money for firms but it's also
getting great health care like you
haven't had before
and we also have to protect the 180
million people with private health care
they want to destroy that I must tell
you we have an election coming up that's
going to be very important for you
people because they want to take it away
they want to bring your taxes up to 80
or 90 percent they started a couple of
months ago at 70 but they really mean 80
or 90 or 95 and that won't pay for it by
the way you need twice that so you have
to be very careful but we'll always be
defending America's rights to have
low-cost high-quality health care of
your choice so important and sadly when
you look at what's going on with
Washington you see a lot of positives
but you also see people that are
fighting very hard they have 25 people
now running for the office of precedent
and some of these people are stone cold
crazy
and they're promoting the biggest
socialist takeover in the history really
of the world because of you think I mean
this is the United States and they have
a hundred trillion dollar green new deal
nobody has any idea what the hell it is
they know that you can't take a plane
anymore you have to take a train to
Hawaii travel I trained to Australia and
a train hey if they can't build from San
Francisco to us what's gonna happen when
they say let's go the train here let's
go to Europe fast train plane go six
I don't want them back time to pivot I
want them to go with this stuff but we
still have to be careful and it'll never
happen as long as I'm president so
[Applause]
you're friends of mine I know a lot of
people in the room and a home ownership
and what you do as Realtors and as real
estate people this is a part of
Americana this is a great great thing we
do you work hard you love people you
love this land you love this country
you take care of employees in some cases
you are employees and you love the
person that they scared you but you're
very very special people I know so much
about what you do because I get the same
thing can you believe it now it's almost
just Joe's house what you are gaining a
lot of experience you negotiate you deal
with farm people you deal with people
that live right next door we do
everything you're very smart and you
love your business
and enjoy your lives and keep building
and will keep the economy strong so that
had a great time in my great honor thank
you very much
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]